الصراع الامريكي الصيني مكمل وتيك توك جزء
لا يتجزا منه فمن بعد حظر التطبيق على
الاجهزه الرسميه والموظفين الحكوميين في
امريكا واوروبا وكندا كمان حاليا بيدرس
منح اداره الرئيس جو بايدن مزيد من
الصلاحيات للتصدي لتهديد تيك توك وفي كلام
على انه ممكن يكون حتى حظر كامل للتطبيق
امس مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
كريستوفري وفي اجابه على اسئله في لجنه
الاستخبارات في مجلس الشيوخ فاجئنا بتصريح
صادم فقال انه الصين في حال غزل التايوان
فتكتوك راح يكون سلاح اساسي من اسلحتها
كيف مدير الاف بي اي قال انه اولا لانها
ببساطه حتتحكم ببيانات ملايين الاشخاص
اللي بيستخدموا تيك توك وثانيا انه راح
تحاول تؤثر على الراي العام من خلال محتوى
فيديوهات التطبيق يعني حضروره رسميا ايش
معنى كلام منهم ومن كندا ومن اوروبا عن مخ
على الامن القومي ومخاوف النصين كمان
كحكومه لها علاقه بالتطبيق لكن كلام على
انه تيك توك سلاح في حروب هذه جديده يعني
اول مره الصراحه نسمعها تيك توك طبعا من
اول يوم اصلا يعني بتنكر تماما انه اعلاها
اي علاقه مع الحكومه الصينيه وبتقول مو
لاننا شركه صينيه فالحكومه بتتحكم فينا
ورئيس الشركه صرح نصا هذا الاسبوع وقال
حكومه الصين عمرها ما طلبت مننا بيانات او
معلومات مستخدمين وحتى لو طلبت ما راح
نعطيها الشركه كانت اصلا كمان ابدت
استيائها وامتعاضها من حظرها من الاجهزه
الحكوميه في امريكا وكندا واوروبا ويبدو
انه رغم نفي كل الاتهامات لكنها حاسه ان
الحظر هذا حياثر عليها بشكل او باخر وتطمن
الغرب باي شكل
خلينا الان عن اليه جديده في تخزين بيانات
المستخدمين الاوروبيين المحليين هذا العام
وقالت انه راح تعمل قريبا مركز جديد
للبيانات في ايرلندا ومركز في النرويج
وانه اللي راح يدير المركزان طرف ثالث
مستقل ما له علاقه بتيك توك وهذا حيمنع
نقل البيانات خارج المنطقه وراح يتقلص
امكانيه اطلاع الموظفين على بيانات
المستخدمين
احنا من جانبنا لمع هذا الجانب ولا مع ذلك
يعني لكن حقيقه الطرفين جالسين بيعملوا
اشياء بتطرح تساؤلات مهمه بتعني الاف بي
اي لمن يقولوا انه الصين راح تستخدم تيك
توك سلاح في الحرب على التايوان على ايش
معتمده مجرد انه التطبيق صيني يعني طب ما
كده ممكن نقول مثلا انه امريكا بتستعمل
فيسبوك وانستجرام يعني هدولي تطبيقات
امريكيه يعني وعن جانب الاخر كمان اللي
تكتب جلسه بتسويه كمان مو منطقي يعني
اوروبا قالت خايفه على البيانات
مستخدمينها قاموا اخذوا اجراءات اضافيه
لحمايه بيانات المستخدمين طيب ليه ما
عملته كده من اول يعني وليه الان عاملين
للمستخدمين الاوروبيين بعد كمان ما عملتوه
كمان قبلها لمستخدمين الامريكيين هم بس
يعني الاوروبيين والامريكيين المهمين
والباقي مو مهم ينضم الينا صانع المحتوى
التقني فيصل السيف اهلا فيك معنا فيصل
فيصل انا طبعا موضوعي معك عن تيك توك
واللي بيصير من امريكا وكذا بس انت الان
موجود في مؤتمر بيبان باين وراك انه ما
شاء الله المكان يعني عامر فاحكي لي ايش
بيصير عندك كيف المؤتمر
الشركات ناشئه والمتوسطه شيء جدا عظيم ولا
عمرها صارت 20,000 فرصه
اي مباشر بشكل جدا رهيب في النص ساعه بدل
تقريبا طيب خلينا نترك بيبان وبالتوفيق
طبعا
للمؤتمر كل شيء خلينا ننتقل الان لتيك توك
لما نقول انه الامريكان او الاف بي اي
تحديدا طالعين وبيقولوا انه الصين راح
تستخدم تيك توك سلاح يعني هل هذا الكلام
منطقي يعني يستخدم كسلاح في حرب
ممتاز جدا السؤال لو رجعنا لمثال فيسبوك
ستسلحه اما لو تكلمنا السلاح فما انه ما
يبغوا النتيجه حقتها في ساعتها يسموها
سلاح بس لو كانوا متطمنين للنتيجه او بخاط
هذا الامر صار توجيه ساعتها واستخدام احد
الادوات اوكي يعني لو انا مثلا من الصين
الان اقدر اقول لهم طب ما انتم كمان عندكم
سلاح فيسبوك مثلا
100% الفيسبوك نتكلم على انستغرام نتكلم
على
منصات جوجل وغيرها في جعل محتوى يظهر عن
محتوى طيب الان معلوماتنا نحن موجودين
يعني مثلا عند ابل عند سامسونج عند يعني
كل احد موجوده اللي بنستخدمه عندهم
معلوماتنا كيف ممكن يستخدموا هذه
المعلومات لانه الواضح انه هو اللي بينظر
له كالشيء الاساسي او الذهب الحقيقي هي
المعلومات كيف ممكن لدوله تستفيد من
المعلومات
ممتاز تكلمنا عن دوله تستفيد من المعلومات
من خلال التطبيقات اللي حيحصلوا عليه
اطباع ونقدر نقول تفضيلات هذا الشخص لما
يشاهد من محتوى عمره ما كان اقامته
من محتوى اهتماماتها وغيرها المعلم هل
المعلومات ما تعتبر شيء حساس عادي اساسي
هذه المعلومات يعتبر اشياء بسيطه امام
معلومات اخرى تتوفر عند الدوله من ناحيه
الهويه تاريخ الميلاد ايضا الارصده
الحسابات هذا شيء مختلف
منصه حساب تواصل اجتماعي بان المعلومات
اللي عندها هي معلومات سريه وخطيره
وبالتالي هي فيها اثر عالي ابدا معلومات
اطباع الناس مستخدمين المنصه اكثر من اي
شيء ثاني يعني بس يقدروا يخلقوا راي عام
يعني
صح يقدر يخلق وراء عام بحيث انه انواع
المحتوى التي تساند ارائهم يدفوها
بالخوارزميات لناس يمكن ما يكون عندهم هذا
الميول مع الوقت مع التكرار يغيروا رايهم
طيب بس لما في نفس الوقت نجي على الناحيه
الثانيه وبنشوف انه تيك توك بتقول طيب يا
جماعه لا تقلقوا اول شيء الامريكان راحوا
عملوا لهم انه مكان داخل امريكا يشيل
المعلومات او البيانات المستخدمين هناك
الاوروبيين الان بيقولوا لهم حبايبي يلا
نحن كمان حنسوي لكم الان نفس الشيء طيب
معناه في شيء في الموضوع يعني مدام بيسووا
خطوات زي كذا وبعدين نحن بيانات يعني
في كل دوله من هيئات اتصالات هم لهم
الحقيه بالذات في المعلومات المستخدمين في
الدوله انها تبقى المعلومات في الدوله
المستضيفه بنفس المستخدمين فاذا المستخدم
في امريكا عادي هي مساله استضافه معلومات
بس الموضوع ما هو بالامني زي ما هم يتخيل
بس محوره الكلام واستخدامه لم هذا الامر
اللي قاعد يصير هذا الامر شفناه عبر 15
سنه حقت هي السنوات الماضيه ما كانت القوه
الاعلاميه بتواصل اجتماعي موجوده الا عند
الامريكان وبالتالي لما صار في منصه
تتنافس بشكل ضخم مع اقتصاد امريكي كبير من
شبكات التواصل وايضا مع مستخدمين صاروا
يقدروا يتم تاثيرهم من منصه خارجيه عن
تاثيرها من منصات داخليه هنا قلنا عن
الموضوع انه لا في تغيير عام وفي اشياء
جدا حساسه ممكن الامر واكيد وواقعي ولكن
العلاقات الحميده تسبب عدم وجود هذا
التوتر ما بينها بس تعرف كمان فيصل يعني
كمان يعني الصينيين لما بيجوا بيقولوا تيك
توك انه لا عمرهم ما بيطلبوا منا معلومات
الحكومه احنا مالنا دخل فيهم يعني هذه
واسعه كمان شويه معلش يعني
صادقه ومعاكي حق ولكن الامر بطبيعه الحال
مع كل المنصات الحكومات تطلب منها معلومات
نفس المسجلين في المنصات امر طبيعي وما
منه خجله وما منه شيء
تويتر وكذا بيطلعوا تقارير دوريه بيتكلموا
عن طلبات الحكومات منهم يعني صح
فالامر حميد كويس بس استخدام هذا الامر
واللي هو اتوقع انه الجانب الاقتصادي هو
اللي قاعد ياثر على امريكا اكثر من اي
جانب ثاني حيث انهم ينصه غير امريكيه تحصل
على اموال المسلمين في امريكا على هذه
المنصه واول كانت الحاله انه الفيس
وانستجرام المنصات الامريكيه تعلن عليها
المعلنين الامريكي فالفلوس منهم وفيهم
الحين الفلوس تطلع لبره هنا المشكله
الاقتصاديه واللي واجهتها هواوي ايضا في
تقنيات الجوالات اوكي طيب تسلم لي يا فيصل
واستمتع بيفان وشكرا لك كان معنا صانع
المحتوى التقني فيصل السيف شكرا لك
[موسيقى]